it's very intimate relationship a lot of
things are changing constantly
i don't want them to feel uncomfortable
with them changing things
on the contrary i want them to move
[Music]
okay rona segev thank you so much for
being on my show 20 minute leaders how
are you good
thank you for inviting me i i am so
honored to have you here
we've been trying to do this for a while
and i'm so happy that you feel better
and that we're finally getting to do
this because
you're one of the leading investors in
israel founding partner
at tlv partners one of the leading
investor funds in israel but you were
also general partner at pitango
with countless of successful investments
over the past
years uh both in the israeli tech
industry and outside of it
rona who are you to give give me a
little bit of background as to who you
are and how do you get
to become a leading investor
well who am i
uh it's just the first question
well i can tell you about how i started
my career which is kind of like weird
i started by learning psychology and
philosophy in the hebrew university
nothing to do with high tech
when i was 24 i had this crazy idea to
to do something in computers
uh it was 95 we didn't have vcs in
israel back then
and i didn't know the world the startup
uh
so everything was really really new but
i found someone who was crazy enough to
give me 200k
and we started and eventually what we
did was we did we
were a company that was developing uh
should the map games like
really hardcore gaming kind of uh
company um
we developed three games one of them
even became
kind of a hit not a big hit
okay there is even a retro about it you
can
find the internet if you want to
embarrass me it's called virus
uh and then i saw the company when i was
27.
uh wow i'm then pregnant with my first
set of twins so i have two sets of twins
wow that's amazing
as well yeah and the main reason i
joined the vc back then was because i
thought to myself oh you're now a young
mom for at least two
three years it's probably not very wise
to be an entrepreneur again
let's do something you know easier uh
and this is why i joined the music
community i joined evergreen back then
uh
incredible so so take me back
because it sounds like there's a little
bit of discrepancy between
where you are at 24 and what you've
studied to
going into the gaming industry what was
the trigger there why
why gaming we started with something
which was
the initial concept was taking lego and
putting it on computers
uh but at that time there was something
which was called edutainment
and we found ourselves inside this
segment which was a horrible segment
full of kind of multimedia
and i i just didn't like it i thought to
myself we don't want to be there
uh and then we said okay let's take this
robot that we're building with those
lego and let's go and fight and and
we just basically kind of copied doom
and started to do games which are
very similar to doom and things you know
uh
kind of followed each other you know and
yeah and very quickly we became a
kind of a pure gaming company
and and that is until you're 27 where
you saw the company you become a vc
and you start to invest in other
companies talk to me a little bit about
this
this transition going from entrepreneur
to an
investor and and and what are some of
the sort of
thought processes that take you
throughout this journey
so it was a very humbling experience
actually because
i was an entrepreneur in the gaming
industry and when i joined evergreen
and we were dividing fields among us
then no one wanted enterprise software
and security it's funny but back then
we're talking about 99 2000 it wasn't
considered to be a very good area to
invest in
so and i was the most junior the new the
new junior
female partner so they gave me kind of
like handed me they said
it's like went through nothing and i
started to invest in enterprise software
i didn't know anything so
and really sometimes i apologize for
entrepreneurs i met back then
and you uh they were talking about all
kind of like rich stuff
which now they are so natural to me but
back then i i just
really i didn't understand a word i
remember the first three months i was
going back home to my husband every
night and crying saying i would never
understand what they're talking about
wow but i was just asking a lot i just
started asking i was
asking questions constantly and this is
one thing that i've learned since
never to be ashamed that you don't know
something you can learn okay just
just tell the person you know i'm not
familiar can you please
kind of tell me more about it and so the
first year and after years i was
basically listening
okay and learning and going you know and
became
you know close friends different
entrepreneurs and different people in
the industry and i was just going and
asking
for explanations uh and then i started
to invest
and i was lucky i must say yeah because
i think
when i started to invest in enterprise
software and security this was exactly
the time it was like
2002 that those areas became hot areas
in israel and
a lot of the exit kind of became united
for software and security
and here i was you know in the perfect
time in the perfect
industry just starting my career and
very quickly i started to have my exits
and you know the rest is history and
right now i think it's interesting
because they say a lot that you know
to be a successful entrepreneur you have
to like timing is one of the most
critical aspects it's not just about
your team and about your
your execution it's about whether the
market is right for your execution to
to go into that market and it sounds
like that's a very similar experience to
what you had as an investor
you're coming in it's 2002 the cyber
security space and enterprise space is
booming in israel and you get to be
there
just as you're you've built the
confidence right to to start making
these investments
and so one of the things that we chatted
a previously just
a little bit about and i'd love to
elaborate here is this whole notion of
of what it takes to succeed
in the field that you're in uh while i'm
sure that a lot of times it may be cut
throat and it's very competitive
i i read in a few in a few places your
take on
on the type of personality that it can
be as you go about your journey so talk
to me a little bit about about that
i think one of the things that i didn't
like about my career
and i didn't like about the industry and
i'm not talking specifically about
israel though we see it a lot in israel
but i also i'm working a lot with vc's
in the u.s and
i see it also in the us and is
is a culture which is very very
aggressive
and i call it very kind of focused on
short-term optimization and
the reason i'm calling it short-term
optimization is because sometimes i feel
that whenever two people are in the room
kind of arguing about something someone
has to win no matter what are the
consequences and doesn't matter even if
it's kind of like
how much you get for your lunch every
day or
or covering your travel costs or stuff
stuff like that which are
really insignificant to the company and
can really damage the company if the
employee feel that
they're not getting enough but still
just because of the dynamics of
of kind of power in the room a lot of
many times there it's very hurtful at
the end of the day to the company
i felt it also in the relationship
between vcs and entrepreneurs
if you think about it kind of like
really like if you
take all the noise and just focus on the
essence of our
job the only way that we can be
successful is if our companies and our
entrepreneurs will be successful
and right really is everything about vc
investment so
if you start playing around with your
entrepreneurs firing them kind of
the chances of your companies to be
successful are
reduced dramatically so basically you
are investing in people
and you're with really the the aim of
this investment and what will make
me successful is that if my
entrepreneurs will be successful
and everything is built around that and
so i didn't understand why people are
fighting
with their entrepreneurs so much why
they're trying kind of to squeeze them
out of things why they're not creating
this alliance
of interns and working together
this was something that really bothered
me for many many years
and this was one of the drivers of
starting tlv partners
um to prove to myself first of all that
we can you can be very successful and
not work uh and work differently
sometimes i think that people are seeing
too many american movies
and we are too much influenced by tv
that you know like this
successful figures are always kind of
like really vicious
and aggressive and totally concentrated
on their needs
uh and and we just we grow up thinking
that this is the only way to be
successful
okay uh and i actually because i was
you know i grew up in jerusalem i just
truly believe that it's not true
that actually working with people in
collaboration and creating a win-win
environment
will actually create a situation where
people want to work with you again and
again they recommend their friends and
and it's just so much you know it's it's
just fun
working like that just everyone enjoys
working together instead of suffering
and kind of like being in conflict
constant conflict
100 so the the forming of tlv partners
today
every entrepreneur and israel and and
many abroad know of toby partners but
talking to the early days so going back
to just
just starting out previously you were at
pitango another
wonderful investment firm in israel and
and what so so i understand the trigger
to form tlb partners it's your own
there's a different mentality you're
defining the culture
so a lot of entrepreneurs that i talk to
they're talking about how culture was
one of the things that they set out to
just to to right concentrate on from day
one you're saying also
it's the same thing in vc i want my
partners and myself to have a certain
culture with our founders
what are some of the greatest challenges
and maybe joyous events
of of starting tlv partners and
throughout this journey
so the first thing was just going out
and pitching this message as i just told
you to lp's to our investors
right and i was really scared i thought
that they're looking to see
people you know like with knives kind of
like walking around like blood
and i was afraid that they would look at
me and say she's weak okay or she's too
nice
or it won't work right right turned out
and but we were very true to our message
because
really we we actually really believe
that this is something that we wanted to
do and it was very important to us that
rlps will understand what is the culture
that we're trying to build
it turned out that just like two or
three years before
us many of the lps started to realize
that vcs that are
actually following this type of culture
are more successful are as successful as
very kind of
tough and cruel vcs because
entrepreneurs like them because they
recommend
others to come and get their money
because
overall the experience working with them
is more pleasant so entrepreneurs are
more focused on building the company and
not fighting with the pcs
so right actually it was received very
well this message which was a big
surprise a very pleasant surprise
to birthday time and me and we raised
our first fund very quickly
i took us a few months to raise 110
million dollars
uh for israel this is amazing you know
that time yeah 2015
vcs were raising funds for like three
years so it took them like three years
to raise a fund so
uh and we raised like from one really
top tier in the us so
it was i remember when we did the
closing i was so happy
i was like you couldn't believe that
we made it like an entrepreneur raising
a fund
it's totally you know we have on
investors we're going out there kind of
like asking for money if someone is
saying no
many times it's just because they don't
like us
uh it's similar actually yeah what is
the pr
how is your relationship with with the
founders that you invest and i know
quite a few of them
and so i i know that it's a wonderful
relationship but but i'd like to know
a little bit about your side of it so as
a as
a vc you know you get to meet with your
entrepreneurs once in a while you get to
help them
on their journey they go you're in the
trenches with them obviously in a lot of
the cases
what are some of the key points in time
that that you are valuable for the
entrepreneurs that work with you
so first of all it's really important to
say that it's very different from with
each entrepreneur because they are
different people
so like it's just like with everyone you
know like you have one personality and
another personality and there is kind of
a natural connection sometimes
it goes one way sometimes it's very
intimate sometimes just very friendly
it really depends some of them are
calling me like 20 times a day some of
them are calling me once a month
and and we have always we have i i book
an hour for
for each entrepreneur uh every week and
they know they can cancel it whenever
they want i don't care
it's for them it's not for me okay i get
a free hour it's fine
right so this is something which is
really important because
and those relationships are also
changing with time
uh so as we get to know each other
better they're becoming more intimate
and kind of like uh
and different and this is something
which for me it's important because
those are real relationships it's not
something that you just turn on and off
it's kind of like real friendships and
and they're there forever
one of the things that they know is that
i really do care and not just about the
company but also about them personally
i do believe that people and companies
are interconnected
and i think that happy entrepreneurs are
better entrepreneurs and i really like
the entrepreneurs i invest and i
insist on investing in people that i
like i really personally like
so we're going to have fun amazing
together
but but how do you how do you go about
the due diligence process then how do
you how do you find that connection
because even if you do get to meet them
a few times
i imagine that the scenario and you know
through through the limited experience
that i now have
with a venture funded that i work with
you know you get to build some sort of
repertoire and relationship with it with
the founders but it's still in the
context of you know three or four
meetings
it doesn't it's not like going camping
with them and seeing them
you know in necessarily in their true
100 colors right so so
it sounds like there's a little bit of a
challenge there to really find the
the personal fit or maybe i'm wrong
no no it is listen i i invest mainly in
seed companies and i really like new
markets okay so markets that do not
exist yet
um there's a real problem in investment
think about it so first of all i invest
in people
and i love first time entrepreneurs so i
think 70 percent of my
time so i know people that have back
record
okay so i can check their track record
in markets that do not exist so there is
not a lot of point talking to customers
a lot of time they don't know what i'm
talking about even so most of the time
goes to working with the entrepreneur
so it's it's it's a weird so
really honestly my due diligence is very
intuitive and it's a lot about
how i feel about the people and if i
think that they're really bright
very open um very transparent and we can
work together
and i call it going together to an
adventure because i know that everything
is going to change the only thing
will not change is the group that is
working together
uh this is why i also like to invest
alone at the seed stage because
it's very intimate relationship a lot of
things are changing constantly
i don't want them to feel uncomfortable
with them changing things
on the contrary i want them to move uh
and i want them to to kind of brainstorm
with me but tell me that
i'm wrong or i'm stupid and feel
comfortable saying that
and insist on doing their own way
because they're the ones who are going
to be blamed eventually if it's not
going the right way so they have to take
the decisions there is a circle of kind
of
responsibility an authority that has to
be closed together and so it's really
important that they'll
take the decision so they need to be
very comfortable with me
and not think that i'm kind of like
telling them what to do so
it's a combination i learned a lot about
people when i'm doing the negotiation on
the term with them
and the way we i'm doing negotiations is
actually very funny i come
with the cup table and we play with it
together and i find a very fair deal to
everyone
and with most interviews with the what
what did you say
we have an interactive cap table so we
just come and we just play with it
okay it's kind of like it takes between
two to three minutes
okay it really depends how long it cut
because it's really easy
yeah because i know that i i don't want
to dilute them too much and they need a
certain amount of money
and we need some ease off so it's
actually very
you know everything about vc
entrepreneurs relationship is
actually really really simple uh and
then you see some entrepreneurs are just
so happy to see this
approach and like in five minutes we
close the deal and we move on
as our entrepreneurs try to optimize and
and those entrepreneurs are usually shy
away
because my kind of attitude
you can take advantage of me okay so i
kind of take care
i work with people that enjoy this kind
of attitude kind of like giving and they
give back and we just
we're working together uh so
it's for that i make mistakes but it's
very rare actually i work with
really great group of people that's just
uh
that's just inspiring i can imagine i
had the situation
you know what one set of you know the
regular vc experience that i think
every young entrepreneur imagines is you
know sitting coming with suits
negotiating over a table
sending emails and over weeks trying to
decide on on those two percentage points
here and there
whereas you come and meet at a coffee
shop do an interactive cap table and
and and give a hug and continue well hug
before corona times of course
and continue with the day rona i can't
believe 20 minutes are almost over but i
have two important questions before we
leave the first one
is to me uh something that a young
entrepreneur like myself or like a lot
of my friends either from 8200 or
stanford
what can we take with us from this
personal insight that you've had of of
being sort of a mention being a good
person
going throughout our career what what
are some what is something that we can
keep in mind
to to try to do that to with that aim
so first of all believe really
really believe in yourself and believe
that it's okay
to be fair and to be mentioned to be
good and it's not like you're weak
sometimes you know like people around us
will consider it weakness it's not it's
actually
being strong and second pick the right
people around you
okay you cannot be fair if you have
people that
are over optimizing that are
manipulative around you pick the right
people around you people that actually
enjoy this kind of culture
and everyone will have so much fun
working together
amazing amazing rona last one
three words that you would use to
describe yourself there is this guy that
i really like in the valley that looked
at me like a year ago and told me
you're such a strange bird so
i love it i love it thank you very very
much this was
inspiring uh just love getting to know
you better and
and i look forward to coming one day
with uh with my own idea and potentially
collaborating together this is uh
it's just wonderful what you're doing
there thank you
bye